total cela une gifle à monsieur et
madame tout le monde
si ottawa est de bombardier ce sera un
bar ouvert dénonce le message
radiophonique diffusée uniquement à
l'extérieur du québec
ça fait des semaines que la fédération
canadienne des contribuables cherche à
mobiliser le public
il ne se passe pratiquement pas une
journée sans que les ministres soient
interpellés sur la demande aide
financière de bombardier pessac pour le
gouvernement trudeau
le dilemme est tout si grand que la
pression des responsables pour l'argent
des contribuables il faut examiner le
plan d'affaires de bombardier
nous allons prendre une décision
responsable basée sur les faits et
l'intérêt pour les canadiens après
québec après la caisse de dépôt
bombardier continue de cogner à la porte
de tahoua bombardé c'est comme une
espèce de marathonien honorablement fait
tout le trajet et on est à quelques
mètres de l'arrivée et la nôtre
marathonien s'est essoufflé est en train
de s'effondrer et il faut l'emmener
jusqu'à cette ligne la décision du
gouvernement trudeau pourrait faire la
différence très cruciale et délicate et
je dirais déterminant décisive même si
le temps presse
ottawa demande d'être patient l'enjeu
est à la fois politique économique avec
une quarantaine de députés du québec le
gouvernement libéral fait face à tout un
casse-tête comment on peut aider sans
nécessairement créer des précédents pour
les autres secteurs et est en conformité
en conformité avec les règles du
commerce international qui interdisent
les subventions gouvernementales
ottawa doit donc trouver moyen
d'intervenir sans provoquer de
contestation des pays dont les
avionneurs concurrence bombardier bref
dans ce contexte les options sont plutôt
limitées moi je crois beaucoup plus qui
va aller vers des politiques de prêts
garantis remboursables
donc ça ça passe mieux une recette
maintes fois utilisée par le
gouvernement fédéral une forme d' aide
déguisée
mais il faut savoir que depuis 1966
bombardier a reçu d'ottawa 1 milliard
300 millions $ en contributions
remboursables mais que l'entreprise n'a
remboursé que moins de la moitié de
cette somme
543 millions faut faire attention quand
les subventions sont conditionnels à
quelque chose et ça c'est important
aujourd'hui parce que bombardier
commence à avoir un comportement je
dirais qui est de moins en moins
socialement acceptable c'est à dire
c'est à dire par exemple sur le plan
fiscal sont pas d'aider des élèves je
dirais model modèle doit aussi
bombardier quand même discutable il ya
des gens qui est des voies que celles
air forcé par weepu l'aider mais pour le
commun est important puis il faut des
garanties de réussite ce n'est pas noir
ou blanc que le fédéral vole au secours
de bombardier ou non il risque d'y avoir
critique et mécontentements ici margot
pour radio canada à ottawa